das ist absolut mind blowing materie
erzeugt aus purem licht dass genau das
möglich ist hat ein physiker bereits vor
rund 90 jahren vorhergesagt und jetzt
endlich die premiere mit der hilfe eines
teilchenbeschleunigers konnte diese
theorie nun erstmals in der praxis
demonstriert werden durch die kollision
von lichtteilchen entstanden materie
ganz ohne weitere schritte und noch eine
weitere these von werner heisenberg
konnte erstmals experimentell bestätigt
werden zwei klicks um science im future
geht es dreimal pro woche spannendes
heinz videos abonniert den kanal und
aktiviert die glocke nur so verpasst ihr
nichts los geht's
herzlich willkommen und vielen dank an
neil für den tollen themenvorschlag den
du uns über unsere teller gruppe
geschickt hast der link zu telegram ist
hier unter me und in der video
beschreibung da bekommt ihr die videos
früher und ohne werbung und können
themen vorschläge machen
gleich elf mal c quadrat die wohl
bekannteste formel von albert einstein
sie beschreibt das energie und materie
äquivalent sind heißt also im klartext
materie lässt sich in energie umwandeln
und umgekehrt der eine weg findet sich
zum beispiel in der sonne hier
verschmelzen atomkerne und aus dieser
materie wird dann energie in form von
strahlung auch bei der explosion von
atombomben kann man das beobachten hier
wird materie in energie umgewandelt aber
auch bei einem simpel lagerfeuer wird
materie in wärme und licht umgewandelt
aber andersrum das war bisher unmöglich
bisher forschungsteams weltweit war es
bisher nicht gelungen genau das auch in
der praxis umzusetzen alle experimente
waren gescheitert denn benötigt wird
dafür an leser der energiereiche
gammastrahlen photonen in einem
hochkonzentrierten strahl abgibt aber
genau einen solchen leser gibt es bis
heute nicht doch jetzt der durchbruch
denn nun ist es physikerinnen und
physikern endlich geglückt auch im
experiment diese theoretische vorhersage
zu beweisen eine absolut spannende und
spektakuläre premiere das us
forschungsteam hat also tatsächlich
materieteilchen aus purem licht erzeugt
dafür wurden energiereiche photonen
einem teilchenbeschleuniger zur
kollision gebracht wie das experiment
genau ablief und ob damit nun
tatsächlich eine theorie bewiesen werden
konnte dessen beweis bislang als
unmöglichkeit all diese spannenden infos
und noch viel mehr gibt es jetzt bei
pixum science and future aus
lichtteilchen die kollidieren wird
materie das gab es bisher nur in der
theorie und diese theorie ist schon
ziemlich alt fast 90 jahre um genau zu
sein die beiden physiker john wheeler
und gary breit hatten im jahr 1934 die
theorie aufgestellt dass durch die
kollision von zwei sehr energiereichen
photonen ein elektron und ein positronen
erzeugt werden kann materieteilchen also
eine erweiterung von einsteins wohl
berühmtester formel gleich mal c quadrat
doch schon damals war den beiden
wissenschaftlern klar dass ihre theorie
höchstwahrscheinlich eine theorie
bleiben sollte eine theorie dessen
beweis die beiden physiker vor knapp 90
jahren für unmöglich jahr zitat
hoffnungslos hielt dazu sagt der
us-physiker zhaoxu der an dem aktuellen
experiment beteiligt war breit und lila
war bereits klar dass dies fast
unmöglich praktisch umzusetzen wäre denn
um licht in materie umzuwandeln bräuchte
es wohl einen laser der gammastrahlen
photon abgibt und zwar in einem
hochkonzentrierten streit das muss man
sich mal vorstellen fast 90 jahre weiter
und noch immer konnte genau solch ein
leser nicht entwickelt werden
stattdessen wurde jede hoffnung in eine
andere methode gelegt statt einem photon
strahl werden beschleunigte schwerionen
als lichtquelle genutzt denn bei einer
extrem hohen beschleunigung können stark
positiv geladenen atomkernen um sich
herum starke elektromagnetische felder
erzeugen deren physikalische
eigenschaften sind mit denen der photon
vergleichbar zumindest unter bestimmten
bedingungen ein ion ist nach der theorie
der beiden physiker von vor rund 90
jahren also von einer wolke aus
lichtteilchen umgeben wenn es sich durch
einen teilchenbeschleuniger bewegt und
jetzt kommt es wenn sich zwei diese
atomkerne in einem solchen beschleuniger
aufeinander zu bewegen und es dabei fast
zu einer kollision kommt interagieren
ihre jeweiligen photonen wolken teile
davon werden beschleunigt und es kommt
zu einer kollision
extrem energiereichen lichtteilchen john
wheeler und gregory breit hatten damals
die theorie aufgestellt dass dann paare
von elektronen und positronen entstehen
materie also bereits seit vielen
jahrzehnten tüfteln forschungsteams
daran diese theorie endlich auch im
experiment zu zeigen so auch fachleute
aus london und mit dabei auch der
physiker stewart mails als canori breit
und john wheeler dem mechanismus im
januar 2 34 erstmals vorschlugen nutzen
sie die damals neue theorie der
wechselwirkung zwischen licht und
materie die sogenannte
quantenelektrodynamik während jede
andere fundamentale voraussage der
quantenelektrodynamik seitdem
experimentell demonstriert wurde wurde
der zwei photonen breitwieser effekt
bislang nie beobachtet die londoner
fachleute hatten bereits vor sechs
jahren 2014 nach einer möglichkeit
gesucht licht erstmals in materie
umzuwandeln andere forschende hatten
eine methode vorgeschlagen die auf
normalen laser basiert so sollten
quantenphysikalische kettenreaktion in
gang gesetzt werden über die
letztendlich dann die materie teilchen
erzeugt werden könnten im experiment
umgesetzt wurde diese idee noch nicht
und so stand ein endgültiger beweis für
die theorie von wiler und breit weiter
aus doch jetzt endlich der durchbruch es
fachleute haben dafür die idee mit den
schwerionen aufgenommen ihr wichtigstes
instrument der star detector am
relativistischen collider lhc in bruck
haye mit der hilfe des staates detektors
soll die bildung und die eigenschaften
des quark gluon plasmas
genau untersucht werden es handelt sich
um einen materie zu stand der
möglicherweise bei ausreichend hoher
energiedichte existieren kann eine super
spannende sache doch trotzdem eine
riesige herausforderung dazu einer der
beteiligten forscher hamburg zu die
bedingungen zu schaffen um diese theorie
zu beweisen ist nicht nur sehr
anstrengend sondern auch ziemlich
aufregend für das aktuelle experiment
nutzen die us physikerinnen und physiker
gold kerne die sie dann auf 99 9 prozent
der lichtgeschwindigkeit beschleunigt
die teilchenstrahlen brachten sie zur
kollision und die zerfallsprodukte
wurden genauer untersucht das
forschungsteam suchte ihr nachfahren von
elektronen und positronen deren
eigenschaften zum beispiel effekt unter
den vorliegenden bedingungen passen
könnten ins visier nahmen die fachleute
dafür beispielsweise die
massenverteilung die quantenzustände die
flugbahn und energie und die ganze
arbeit hat sich gelohnt denn am ende
wurden insgesamt
6085 elektronen positronen paare
aufgespürt die die passenden merkmale
mit sich brachten und diese materie
teilchen passen nach ansicht des
forschungsteams genau in das schema sie
weisen alle eigenschaften auf die die
fachwelt für die entstehung von photonen
kollisionen vorhersagt noch nicht nur
dass die us physikerinnen und physiker
analysierten zudem auch noch ob die
photonen dem umfeld der atomkerne
erzeugt worden waren die merkmale
normaler lichtteilchen aufweisen und
auch das ist nach angaben des
forschungsteams der fall dazu sagt einer
der beteiligten wissenschaftler daniel
brandenburg unsere ergebnisse liefern an
klaren beleg für die direkte in einem
schritt ablaufende erzeugung von materie
antimaterie fahren aus der kollision von
licht so wie es vom breit und wieder
theoretisch beschrieben worden ist
demnach ist es also erstmals tatsächlich
gelungen licht direkt in materie
umzuwandeln das experiment aus den usa
eine echte premiere also das
forschungsteam selbst sieht also damit
den bright wieder effekt als bewiesen an
dazu der physiker zu ich arbeite seit 20
jahren an diesem projekt ich habe einige
aufregende entdeckungen miterlebt und
daran teilgenommen die sie hier stehen
ganz oben auf meiner liste weitere
forschung in diesem bereich könnte
spannende erkenntnisse mit sich bringen
beispielsweise über prozesse im frühen
universum die entstehungsgeschichte des
universums könnte somit besser
verstanden werden der us-physiker
stewart mengels hat er das mal so
zusammengefasst wir würden einen prozess
nach bilden der in den ersten 100
sekunden des universums von bedeutung
war und der außerdem in gamma blitzen
eine rolle spielt den stärksten
explosionen im universum einem der
größten ungelösten rätsel der physik
doch nicht nur diese erkenntnis haben
die us fachleute durch ihr aktuelles
experiment bekommen das zweite große
ergebnis handelt von der licht biegung
im vakuum die forschenden konnten
beobachten dass sich der licht weg durch
ein magnetfeld im vakuum unterschiedlich
biegt und zwar je nach polarisation des
lichts auch dies also die polarisation
unabhängige licht biegung im vakuum
wurde hier zum ersten mal im experiment
demonstriert schon werner heisenberg
hatte sich vor vielen jahrzehnten mit
diesem thema beschäftigt es handelt sich
also um das experiment das zeigt dass
die polarisation die wechselwirkung von
licht mit dem magnetfeld im vakuum
beeinflusst frühere versuche waren
gescheitert da dieser effekt nur in
größeren magnetfelder wirklich sichtbar
wird zu den beiden super spektakulären
ergebnissen dieser aktuellen studie sagt
der us physiker frank götz beide
ergebnisse bauen auf vorhersagen einige
der großen physiker des frühen
zwanzigsten jahrhunderts auf die fünfte
kraft in der physik auch ein wahnsinnig
spannendes thema in diesem video da wird
nämlich unter anderem auch entdeckt dass
atome im inneren ganz anders sind als
wir bisher vermutet haben also anklicken
anschauen und abonnieren gc unter jedem
video mit dem abo button auch hier und
ansonsten bis dann bleib dran